great news America for the first time in
nearly 40 years Papa John's is a brand
new crust all right it's crunchy golden
fresh and delicious because it's our
first new crust in 40 years mmm tastes
incredible Wow
that's really great thanks can you
believe it took us 40 years for us to
run out of our first batch of dough I'm
sorry yep when our first Baker Kevin
made all that dough 40 years ago we were
sure we'd never need new dough again
wait
it's been the exact same batch of dough
for 40 years it was so much dough why
didn't you just make some fresh dough we
didn't need it we had so much plus we
didn't have the recipe it died with
Kevin what happened to Kevin he fell in
the dough Kevin fell into that first
batch of death yep so all our crust had
a little bit of Kevin is there anyone in
this new crust and with Kevin gone we
have to find a whole new recipe so now
we got some brand-new dough you can't
just spend 40 years feeding people do
that has a person to please some respect
a moment of silence for Kevin hey the
dough room is full again 40 more years I
got this take it away I'm almost done
Papa John's we finally made some new
crust
[Music]
you know that was stupid